evening and welcome to fox news
primetime
[Music]
consider the possibility we are led by
idiots
it's a line i've reiterated for years to
our team at the federalist it's written
on a sticker on my laptop it's meant to
serve as a reminder that no matter how
well-meaning our class of unfireable
elitist bureaucrats may seem there's
always the possibility that they are in
reality
very stupid people doing their jobs well
past their prime
and operating with the kind of
taxpayer-funded hubris
that blinds them to their own failings
there have been plenty of examples in
the past
i wrote that line originally about james
comey whose
anonymous social media accounts were
found mere minutes after he teased them
in an interview
but our new example is the god emperor
of covid anthony fauci
whose emails were released in response
to a series of foia requests
and show what a false god he was the
emails
are explosive that's no exaggeration
there's hypocrisy in them
mixed messaging spin there's naivete and
malice
about his unwillingness to accept that
the chinese communist party was
suppressing information
about kova during the early days they
detail an
absolutely scandalous effort by dr fauci
to push the animal theory about the
origins of covid
and undermine the theory that the virus
leaked from a lab
and that effort is even more damning
when you consider this timeline
on april 15th 2020 fox's bret baer
reported
that multiple sources briefed on the
origins of covet 19
were increasingly confident that the
virus sprung from the wuhan lab
the following day april 16th nih head
francis collins forwarded a link to
immediate write-up of bear's hannity
appearance
to dr fauci under the subject line
conspiracy gains momentum
the rest of the message is redacted as
is fouchy's response
why is this redacted why can't you see
this that's the question you should be
asking
the next day april 17th fauci downplayed
the lab league theory to a reporter
saying quote the mutations that it took
to get to the point where it is now is
totally consistent with a jump of a
species from an animal to a human
the day after that april 18th fauci gets
an email from peter dazak
the head of ecohealth alliance which
funneled millions of dollars to the
wuhan lab
thanking him for supporting the natural
origin theory
did you see what just happened there
that's the scientific bureaucracy
circling the wagons in real time and it
should inspire dozens of questions from
every american
but not the american press corps or at
least the ones chosen by the white house
today
they didn't ask a single question on it
remember two democrat members of
congress tried to intimidate cable
providers
into pulling this network off the air
that idea even got a hearing on capitol
hill
the government wants to be able to
enforce their preferred narrative
and most of the media are generally
happy to comply
in that environment we need media
willing to challenge the government
consensus
not government and media outlets that
link arms with facebook
as the emails show dr fauci did to
censor legitimate inquiries
over the past few years we've seen a lot
of reporters patting themselves on the
back
squeezing into embarrassing t-shirts
about how they are the guardians of
democracy
coming up with cringe-worthy taglines
about democracy dying and darkness
all while they were propping up one
false idol after another
from governor anthony cuomo to tony
fauci himself while attacking those
people
like the federalists like the new york
post the daily caller and fox news
for being right all along how do they
get away with it
fauci's eagerness to jump on describing
the lab leak thesis as a conspiracy
shows the twisted nature and enduring
power of dc
elite groupthink the idea goes that
because you have the right degrees the
right connections
you shouldn't be questioned when you
bring your pronouncements down from the
mountaintop
because you are one of raiders of the
lost ark's top
men what you're not interested in
following the science
so what did fauci know and when did he
know it and why does such an obviously
incompetent person have so much power
whether it's in the inconsistency of
framing everything from masking to the
gain of function research
to the truth about the disease's
emergence he doesn't seem to think he
owes anyone an explanation
and it's doubtful that he'll be taking
questions from bret baer anytime soon
in early 2020 there was this impression
that fauci was the indispensable man
like tim geithner in 2009 who had been
preparing his whole life
to lead us through this crisis his
fandom in the media was incredibly over
the top
his mug was put on t-shirts pillows
candles the covers and magazines
but it's now embarrassingly clear that
fauci is at least a decade past his
sell-by date
he's just another buddy buddy senior
democrat in the club bureaucrat fauci is
one of the highest paid employees in the
entire government
these emails show that he said covid
would be no worse than the flu
that estimates of 500 000 dead would be
extremely high
that there was nothing to be done to
really stop the spread since masks
wouldn't work
why are we still paying this guy our
public health experts spent a literal
year
lying to us and their argument in their
defense is what
that it was a noble lie how can we have
public servants if they can't be fired
and now they can't even be pressured to
resign even when they disgrace
themselves while working to destroy our
country
the truth is these rules apply to only
one team
there is no mystery why elites not only
covered up but actively slapped down the
lab league theory in 2020
it couldn't be true even if it was
because trump might have been re-elected
if the story got out
political tribalism won out over truth
and you can see that reflected again
today when i repeat
there were no questions from the white
house press corps
about any of these emails
in the narrative you were peddled by the
corporate propaganda press
fauci became this oracle-like figure who
couldn't be challenged by other
scientists
see scott atlas for how that turned out
and debate the issues
through it all fauci operated with a
complete lack of humility
instead of just being honest and saying
there is a lot we still don't know
instead he repeatedly tried to
manipulate public opinion
on masks on vaccination rates on
everything
because he thought you were too stupid
or ignorant to act like adults
he spent hours on tv and talking to
reporters no booking was too small
no outlet too obscure to print his name
or take his picture by the pool
people in the white house trying to
figure out an actual crisis in our
country
complained at the time that they hadn't
even heard of some of the outlets he was
asking to appear on every day
top doctor indeed understand
these elites are the same people who
have been wrong about everything
for decades how did nixon win no one i
know voted for him as the story of the
last two generations of american
leadership
from the campus bs in the 60s to nixon
to reagan to global cooling to the cold
war to welfare to immigration to
globalization to trump and wmds and the
wars
and hillary's historical significance to
the emerging democratic majority
to beta o'rourke to bernie sanders and
socialism everything
they're wrong like it's their job
in any group of people you're going to
have an elite they're going to have what
power and wealth and some people will be
better at obtaining it than others
no matter how you write the rules there
is going to be an elite who wins the
game
but the collection of fools especially
ones the media fawns over
is just embarrassing at this point when
they're called to perform
they fail we have the wisdom of
america's founders to thank for the way
they set up our constitutional
government
where we should not be ruled by anthony
fauci because ultimately
this isn't about him that's missing the
point it's about the fact that the
founders never intended for us to be
ruled by bureaucrats
no matter how well intentioned no matter
their resume
woodrow wilson did his best to change
that he envisioned rule by the
administrative state
the brilliant bureaucrats decent men in
an indecent time
but as you know it turns out human
nature applies to bureaucrats as well
at some point our government forgot that
it works for us
and started to grumble as bertolt breck
wrote that
the people had forfeited the confidence
of the government and wished
they could dissolve the people and elect
another
but they can't we're here we are awake
and we are not going away here the
people rule
or we should any system of government
where we the people don't rule needs to
end
starting today my grandfather loved star
trek and growing up
we'd watch the old episodes together one
scene sticks in my mind
it's an episode where captain kirk
awakes among a primitive people who
believe him
to be an immortal god but when one of
the aliens challenges him
he's shocked to find his knife draws
kirk's blood he shouts
behold a god who bleeds bureaucracy
inclines toward immortality it's easy to
get a god complex when everyone around
you treats you like a god
if you're a patriot who's awake you
understand that no man let alone a
career
bureaucrat is infallible it's time to
remind your fellow americans
that government is a god who bleeds i'm
ben dominic
and this is the american crisis hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else